[Music]
it is
hate my blogger
so let's get after it and
have it
let's go [__] bread
all right uh resident aguido
Chris Cuomo is doing by the way he knows
that he's getting views on this because
of us by the way he knows it's because
of us he's been doing some more walking
talks
yo what is going on today with with with
with the [__] Chrome brow do not tell
me I'm gonna have to exit all of this
[__] Chrome browser and make this
work please
I am I am going to have to
oh no that's two in a row that's two in
a row you blamed on your boys and it's
your fault I didn't blame you
oh yeah that's right I blamed me yeah
and you were right now it's Chrome's you
you were you were you were right to do
that I'm going to relaunch Chrome now
guess what's about to happen because now
as I relaunch Chrome
um it's going to close everything right
it's going to relaunch and all the
YouTube videos
are going to play
at what at the same awesome I can't wait
all righty you ready
here we go I just clicked it I just
clicked it why don't we just do the show
like that we can just you know get out
of here early
just be sounds great
[Laughter]
a can of coconut meatball sub I'll just
sit here and eat
crinkle my [__] tin foil right next
to the mic
um bro that was forget about doing
heroin and his nose collapsing the whole
show all the time the food was the most
egregious part right
like it was bad enough he was on heroin
and he was always late he was leaving
early but on top of that the fact that
ant would get already for maybe 50
minutes coherently and he would choose
that 50 minutes to also roll out a
[__] meatball sub in a tin foil thing
and just eat it
bro he paid him I mean I don't know dude
like 800 Grand I think he paid him a lot
just eating a [__] sandwich late all
right so here's what I did I had and I
can't believe I had to do this I had to
just quickly
quickly open up uh
uh open this up open up a brave browser
because we're gonna have to watch it on
Brave my Chrome is a goddamn mess here
you go boys here you go is it up it's up
there we go let's go
[Music]
welcome to another walk and talk I'm
Chris Cuomo thank you for subscribing
following checking out the free agent
here
putting the [__] hats back after you
wear them and that's gross
yeah but maybe you'll get one that has
is a smell it'll smell like pasta
pasta hat it's almost like dracar yeah
it does lots of trashy every goddamn
Italian whether it's your carnivore
station
it is uh a little befuddling to me how
many of you who follow me yes you know
what that means befuddling who are part
of the extended fam don't know
he just he extended how did you know
that was going to be my problem they
watched the Pod he
oh I hate him oh I hate him I bet I'm on
television with news Nation it's a
startup uh and that makes sense
did you hear what he's we got to hear
that again we gotta hear this listen to
how sad he is watch scribing just
following checking out the free agent
here checking out news Nation
it is uh a little befuddling to me how
many of you who follow me on social
media who are part of the extended fam
don't know that I'm on television
first of all wow yeah he's really
revealing yes
he's he's bitter man y'all I'm a little
surprised at that surprisingly nobody
nobody knows that we're uh you know
still doing a show you know it's kind of
weird you know because they promised me
like all this advertising money right
what's going to be going into my show
but uh turns out it's none turns out
this is like when Paramount tried to do
like a syndication Network in the 90s so
I'm only in like a couple of markets
it's a mess I'm Chris Cuomo thank you
for subscribing okay following check
chrome back up here let me switch that
over I fixed that
all right well the videos in this all
right uh uh also I can't believe that
you know I go check the P.O box and no
one's got us any free agent merch yet
that kind of bums me out I thought our
fans liked us you know
I would picking out the free agent here
checking out news Nation it is uh a
little it's a little Mom and Pop
it is though I know I know I'm surprised
how many people follow me on social
media don't know that uh I'm still on TV
so my news Nation it's owned by a
company called Spectrum like so if your
internet was ever really bad you might
know them you know it's crazy because uh
you know the other day no one made me
sad
uh my mom goes hey Chris when you're
gonna get back on TV I'm like my I've
been on TV news Nation
how many times I gotta show you my open
up the Roku go to YouTube what channel
on the Roku I thought it was on that you
said it was on television yeah yeah it's
a Roku
yeah it's like a television man it's
like a television inside the television
foreign
to me how many of you who follow me on
social media who are part of the
extended Fam I'm going to call her our
listeners the extended fan from now on
don't know he's turning into Opie you
know that's what's happening right but
I'm on television with news Nation he's
just doing a beer show soon it's a
startup uh and that makes sense
yes this recent measure is like about
less than half of you no yeah I mean
obi's used to doing a show with a
[__] strung out Guido so it's [__]
a match made it happen
that I am back on TV cable TV at news
nation and it's kind of amazing you know
because I'm back on TV and that [__]
sucker is not going to be on TV soon
backstabbing piece of [__] Botox [__]
piece of garbage and I had news Nation
put in my contract they would never hire
Don Lemon
which is odd because they had already
had it in their actual uh company policy
that they were never going to hire
Donald yeah pay another doubt and other
women that want a caddy gay guy around
surprisingly yeah
it turns out they don't mind having a
catty gay guy around but a really mean
spirited one yeah they'd rather have
like is Anderson Cooper yeah somebody
you know who kind of you know you might
make funny earrings but he's not trying
to get you fired but when they shot
behind the scenes
top of the page where you can find it
where you are
it's got pretty good reach okay
another one
it actually has more reach in terms of
households in MSNBC
listen to his talking point it has more
reach in households but you're comparing
it to MSNBC dude
are you kidding me if I throw a rock out
my window it has more reach in MSNBC
it's got more reach than that channel
that's like CNN but doesn't play in the
airport
[Laughter]
to all like the train stations but you
know that whole thing happened so you
know forget that
which is weird because they're barely
covering the train crashes now and
that's kind of odd because they're
playing at the train station
we're on an 8 and 11 Eastern they rerun
the show so
check it out please because that's why
I'm doing it
he is desperate
did you see that yeah because nobody's
tuning in he's starting to learn the
difference between like
basically trying to stand on your own
two legs and draw a crowd versus being
on a place that's on at the airport yeah
exactly it's there's a certain level of
Fame that comes with being on a certain
Channel at a certain time and now it's
like no they hired you to bring in the
audience and that's why he's doing his
walking talks and begging people to turn
in because I guarantee they're already
bitching at him probably too
well good news rumble's going to be
playing exclusive at all go-kart tracks
so if you're at a fun spot give us a
watch I like it
probably have to dial back the cursing
and probably put closed caption on
because gold cards are very loud you're
not gonna be able to hear this
this is the batting cages and kids don't
go to go-kart tracks anymore it's it's
[__] messed out though it's trying to
sell drugs there today at least for me
the three
small also I want to say that uh ROTC
and Rumble are now exclusively also
going to be shown in all of uh Jerry's
Cava and Kratom bars you got us to
Cotton the Sarasota Coast you got us to
Cherry the Jerry's gig hell yeah bro
that's three locations nice nice we're
going to be showing the Latin America
but the one in Hollywood the one in
Miami won't play us I don't know why I
tried really hard
yeah so now a bunch of sad people are
going to sit at a bar drinking their
[__] Kratom tees withdrawing from
heroin playing Mario Kart and staring at
our two dumb mugs sounds great actually
ROTC coming to a local Barcade near you
what was that different than the
the audience it's not that's when it's
perfect are we complaining it's perfect
it's perfect no Virgie it's different in
that we're gonna reach like new like
more of the new same people though yeah
our typical audience are people who buy
food at a bowling alley I honestly am
perfectly fine with that okay
I perfect merged like that one I'm
perfectly fine with that
right so what's wrong with buying food
at a bowling see what I mean versus
that's why you're the producer you get
it
because you're like the king of those
people
get it you don't want any chicken wings
after you're sticking your finger and
finger holes that everyone's used it'll
take five minutes to stop at the Wendy's
on the way
you know what I mean
they do only sell finger foods they do
I know it's okay stick your fingers in
this hole and then eat the chicken wings
you [__] animals every food they sell
is some kind of code for child sex
trafficking or porn it's so true
literally every every food they serve at
a bowling alley sounds like a coated
podesta email yeah because they rape the
kids in the basement you can't hear it
on the count of the bowling alley
it's either cheese pizza hot dogs yeah
yeah who do you think sets the pins up
Mercy
victims
huh hey I got a turkey
at least for me the three when they shut
down Epstein Island like some of those
girls were just like man I don't know
what I'm gonna do now I don't want to go
back to the ball now
all words among the smallest of all
words that can mean the most
an analysis of anything is emotional
factual personal professional but they
can be the most vexing vexing he's
reading books again whose word of word
of a day calendar we pointed out he
always is a new word and frustrating
what are they each asked in the form of
a question it's like Jeopardy I've
played that
why question mark
and question mark what's he saying does
anybody follow in here
no because he's an idiot I haven't
skipped anything
or questions something something pasta
yeah something something
[Laughter]
these are tools for you
[__] and get out of here
by the way
just because I know [__] don't mean
I'm able to Ted Bundy of birds over here
show in terms of money you open his
[__] his man cave freezer and a bunch
of parakeet dead parakeets just falling
on the ground yeah they're not even
flying back here during the Spring
anymore yeah my own life I struggle
mightily I've come to the conclusion
maybe not as talented as you thought you
were without the infrastructure of uh
the CNN is that what you figured out
that when you're out here in the wild
like us it's a lot harder to make a name
for yourself turns out a certain bare
minimum number of people are going to
tune in at Prime Time on CNN every night
no matter what whether whether you're
there or not
yeah yeah because like Merce pointed out
earlier the [__] the guy vacuuming up
the airport terminal needs something to
watch that's it and they won't put
floors and no matter how much he begs
they won't put Telemundo on forum
maybe there is something
these past lives because
this one is proven very difficult for me
I honestly sometimes think to myself
that I'm gonna borrow a line from our
youngest
it's gonna be good you ready
I'm just not good at life
that should be that should be the title
of your next [__] book Chris
no I'm not just not good at life yeah
risk Walmart the chomo project story
followed by Trend hard and eat Clan
how to beat Jack at 52.
I'm not good at living and don't forget
to follow my fitness podcast vascular AF
we'll be talking to the liver King this
week and uh
laughs talking about his all-natural
diet
when she said it
and
I I get it I get it I get it this can be
hard man because it's what you decide to
make it it's what you decide
how about how you're gonna feel and see
it
and that's easy to say but it's hard to
do it's not easy Chris that didn't even
sound easy to say for you
you dumb Guido
remember me try to convince everyone the
afraid I was the same as the n-word it's
one of my favorite schools yeah it was
glitter though that's the n-word for my
people
[Laughter]
Goblin against the shackles I left a
hundred pound dumbbells Rogan even said
it's real let's get after it
especially consistently right
consistency is key in everything that's
the hardest part of any Dynamic at least
in my experience but these three
questions so you have why which you got
why you know like so like why do I cry
and punch drywall every time I'm upset
finally inconvenient
and then who who is affected by me
crying and punching drywall every time
my mind
your poor mother is effective and when
what time of the when what time of the
night am I punching drywall and what
room the neighbors are getting mad at me
and how how am I still married to this
wonderful woman who puts up with me
crying I'm punching a drywall every time
on my own inconvenience turns out the
the answer to all my question is is I'm
very Italian
it turns out
I'm an [__]
a coma who's an [__]
Chris Cuomo and Sebastian Maniscalco to
do it no no do not will that into the
world Marsh
you're right it would be him being all
chill and Chris [__] flip it out oh
God he's just like sometimes I don't
understand like you're like real
confused trying to sound so smart it's
okay Chris we're Italians we don't have
to be smart we're loud
laughs
okay I'm going into chat GPT now
Italians we don't have to be smart we're
loud
[Laughter]
yes please make get get me a sick a
Chachi BT sitcom
where buddy cop buddy cop where okay so
one of them Sebastian the other one's
Chris Chris is very angry and there's a
dirty Sebastian's very Italian okay
Chris Chris Cuomo and and Sebastian are
the new face of Law and Order SVU
yes yes yes there it is yes yes solving
SVU cry yes and hold on iced tea is
still in it
make sure iced tea is still in this in
this one okay thank you that's what I
want we'll read it we'll read it just
get it done and send it to me
only be asked this question right the
most important question
ever invented
even in journalism
well have you ever done that how would
you know adrenal Elizabeth
unless journalism is a new [__] brand
of d-ball I don't think you've ever
taken or done it I don't think you wave
in a [__] uh a comically large Q-tip
around yeah journalism covering up his
[__] rapes was uh journalism
attempted rapes
what where when how all important never
been
my Pursuit why is everything to me it
always has been it's what brought me
into the media
it's really the only question
that fascinates me
in most Dynamics
and it's where I struggle most
why
why do you feel like people trying to
find meaning is like my favorite thing
in the world yeah it really is such a
fun thing as dumb people just try they
want so bad to be smart and get it and
have this insight and you're [__]
you're you're a [__]
[Laughter]
um
you know
um I'm not saying you're wrong I'm just
saying believe that point out uh they'll
get it by context
oh [__] you ever been on this crazy Blue
Marble they call her and thought about
what are we doing here you know it's
like a big meatball
and I'm the garlic you know what Chris I
think you're just overthinking things
oh [__] I'd watch that you know I had a
heartbeat I'd watch that
why did this happen why didn't this
happen
why something is real why something
isn't real
um
often this question is avoided
[Laughter]
pursued but it is fundamental he's like
the Westworld robot where the fly lands
on his eye and like he's too dumb to be
affected by it yeah you're right
you got a real rind on you
yourself
licensed attorney
I mean but I know a lot of licensed
attorneys that are [__] no that's
what I mean I know some licensed
attorneys that are [__] morons
I mean like it's like it's like real
estate agents right like the one test is
pretty hard but then once you nail that
I mean you're pretty much good to go
it's like like fail it once or twice but
once you pass it it's like yeah anyone
can do it they really put the bar on the
ground no pun intended hey oh
that's next to that dead bird
do we have the chat GPT yes check Show
links all righty let's uh we see okay so
here's what we have
okay
it's um
okay uh uh all right so
what
wait I don't mean to play that but that
actually works okay but anyway here it
is
um but it still worked out it worked out
because that's what this is okay so here
it is the Chachi PT thing you ready
uh all right Mercy you might want to
just go into Show links and read it from
there it's gonna be hard for you to read
uh the way it's set up yeah it's it's
never good uh the first thing is a is
like a plot okay so what's what's the
prompt get what's the prompt
like what what what is the uh what did
you pushing to get this so I put in uh
please create a episode of Law and Order
SVU with iced tea Sebastian Maniscalco
and Chris Cuomo where Chris Cuomo is a
dirty cop and he is caught for bird
murder
Okay so
uh which one's first title Law and Order
special units dirty blue
yes okay that that is the premise okay
so the second episode is Law and Order
Special Victims Unit dirty blue okay
opening scene the camera pans over the
city skyline as the sunset showing
various shots of busy streets and
skyscrapers cut to an alley where a
young woman is being attacked by a group
of men Ice-T playing detective to
totally to tutiola and his partner are
in Hot Pursuit they apprehend the
suspect and the credits roll episode one
bird murder bird murderer
damn it the episode opens with the
discovery of a dead bird in Central Park
uh tutio is assigned the case and it's
initially skeptical but soon discovers
that the bird was owned by a wealthy
businessman played by Sebastian
who is willing to pay a large sum of
money to find the person responsible for
the bird's death
you mean to tell me that somebody came
into your home
an Italian comedian and stole your bird
and then killed it meanwhile Chris Cuomo
plays the role of detective Davis that's
not a name for him a terrible name a
member of titiolo's unit Davis is known
for being a dirty cop and is often seen
taking bribes and using his position for
personal gain well that's a little
closer that's pretty on brand all right
all right as the investigation into the
bird's death continues two cellos begin
to suspect that Davis may be involved
the investigation leads to tutiolo and
his team to a pet store where they
discover that Davis purchased poison
similar to the one used to kill the bird
and confronts Davis who denies any
involvement this sounds like an episode
of su though doesn't it and the final
thing David's seen on the phone with an
unknown person discussing the murder of
the bird and his involvement okay so uh
here we go so let's get down here scene
opens with iced tea okay that's the last
one uh you're gonna have to do both
because you do all the voices it's all
you scene open [__] scene opens with
iced tea uh Sebastian Maniscalco and
Chris Coleman interrogation room iced
tea all right Chris Cuomo well let me
get this straight you killed a bird
uh Chris Cuomo looking down in his feet
I killed the bird it was a mistake I
didn't mean to do it uh Sebastian
mascara a mistake how do you actually
how do you mistakenly kill a bird
uh I was trying to show it away and I
guess I hit it too hard
I know it's the crime to kill a
protective Bird right you could be
facing serious jail time
I know I know I screwed up Sebastian
I don't get it Chris you're a respecter
why would you do something like this
it's karma looking up it was a stupid
mistake I didn't think it would be a big
deal iced tea leaning back well it is a
big deal and we got enough evidence to
charge you with a felony Chris Cuomo
nodding I understand
Sebastian sighing
this is a sad day for all of us
for birth murder
a closing scene 20 and his team aren't
seen celebrating their victory at a
local bar with Sebastian joining in on
the festivities iced tea raises his
glasses and toasts to the Justice being
served the camera pans out as a group
continues to celebrate
[Applause]
crap
bro that was
jet gbt is [__] nuts here he goes
in this city bird crimes nobody really
cares about yeah I mean we don't even
really care about human crimes oh we're
frankly
we have actual murders we're not even
investigating anymore oh please someone
animate this please someone take we
appreciate it please do it that was
right
[__] merch doing that [__] Eddie
Murphy doing all the voices hey man I
said we just gotta [__] bang about
him I'm like Justin Roiland